[موسيقى]
مساء الخير عليكم جميعا
سعيد جدا بالكردي معكم اه بما ان ان
اسمحوا لي احكي لكم حكايه بس حكايه
واحده
او الحكايه ها تبقى
حكايه ورقه والحقيقه الثانيه حكايتها
كان يا مكان كان فى ولد اسمه مكان يكو
بيلعب بالورقه في يوم من الايام كان مع
ورقه كبيره جدا والمقصود بها لكن كان سؤال
يسال نفسه طبعا عاملي بالورقه الكبيره
كلها
يمكن ان نص كده بين
والنص
وبردو فكره
انا كمان مساحه احلامي وطموحاتي وافكاري
واحتياجات كانت تشكل وتتغير على حسب ظروف
واوضاع واحتياجات شيء طبيعي وصحه جدا من
شرطه تزيد من الشرطه تكبر لكن كل وقت اللي
احتياجاته
ما كان يكون
الورقه مش عارف يعمل ايه
شفتوا
ابدا
افكار كثير جدا يمكن تطلع منهم بفكره
واحده ما كان يكون فتح الكتاب وبدا ان
صفحه صفحه من صفحات وكل صفحه كان يثير
فكره احلى من اللي قبلها درجه انه حتى
نحتار يعملان هي واحده فيهم
من الكتاب
تربيت في كتاب تربيت قارئ كتاب مهمه جدا
عنده جلسه الحكي حاجه اساسيه هذا ما فيهم
الايام كده اتفرجت على فيلم
وشفت ميتران وهي احدى ومسك الكتاب وبتحكي
لاطفال صغار ينفي المكتبه
الجميل
مخططه على رفض اكبر دليل ان جزء الحكي
مستمر وموجود لكن الاجمل كان ابتسامه
الولاد وهم يعنيهم اللي بتضحك فورت الحج
ومن هنا كان بتاتي مع الحق والحكواتي
تقريبا من سنه الفين
ما كان يكون الكتاب هو مبسوط و فرحان جدا
ومره واحده من طرات عليه ما كان يكون لو
سمحت عشان لازم ينزل علشان روح مشهور
مفاجاه ومفاجاه
انا بس عشان العربيه موجوده تحت ولازم
نتحرك ونمشي
اخر الفين واثناشر اللي كميه اتصالات
ماهوله مناسبه ما يلي هاي السلام الحق
القاهره عام الاعلان عن مدير مشروع مكتبه
متنقله وبصراحه ما فيش احسن من كل وظيفتي
القرارات و تفكير كثير جدا الدين ورغم
انهم كانوا يعرفون ي اللي انعملت ثلاثه
انترفيو اصحاب كل واحده فيهم اللي قبلها
واستقبلت وبمنتهى البساطه الف مبروك
العربيه قضيه بيضه من برا حقيقه من قوه
وعايزه مكتبه متنقله ان مصر كلها
لنا عليها بالرسومات ولا احلى من كذا وكان
للنظر البلد تخصصات كتب الاطفال
الكتب وبدل ما كانت فاضيه من جوه و من بره
بقيت مليانه كمان وبدانا نتحرك بها
ما كان فيه طول الطريق بقي وهو قاعد في
العربيه ما عملت مع حاجه ثانيه وتكون
لتفكيره
الحاجه اللي بنركز عليها انت مركز مع
طياره كان تعرفوا
ايه ان تناول تغير رايك وتغير حلم كانت
طول الوقت اعمال تقول لنا عليه ما كان
يكون شويه كدا لا لا لا انا ما غيرت ابدا
الحلم اللي عندي هو اللي انا عايز اعمالهم
ايوه غيروا مش انا قلت لحضرتك
اننا
بعدما استلمت المكتبه
اللي تكلمت عليها في الاول زادت وتحول كنا
مجرد حلم الامل بدل ما كتب كتاب في مكتبه
احكي والعاب الاطفال في كل الاماكن اعد
كثير بتيجي لمجرد انهم عارفين ان المكتبات
يجي يعني عشان يلعبوا يضحكوا
وبالاخر يلعبون تفكك وكل واحد يروح ومبسوط
والسؤال التقليدي في اخر اليوم ها تيجي
انت يعني
امكانيه القتل ماشي يا سيدي بس انت على
طول بتقول لي بحرا كبير
ممكن اسالك السبب ان ان تؤكد ان قالها
بصراحه انا يمكن ما بيحبش اقوله بس خليني
اقول لك عشان ان تماما برده انا نفسي اطلع
بحار عشان نفس جدا وهو كان دائما بيحكي
الوجود
الاصول تحياتي لها عوامل مهمه جدا من اول
جدي اللي كان
العربي وكانت اقسام تحياتي انا اتفق عليه
وهو بيكتب او كيتي رحمه الله عليها
وحكاياتها اللي منها شحال والمؤثره فيها
لحد الوقت الاخير طبعا انها حبيبتي في
حاجه اسمها الرد والاذاعه اللي كان بيمشي
البيت على نظام ما يختلف ولا يوم على حسب
البرامج اللي بتشتغل في الاذاعه والدي
والرسم ومهاراته في الرسم والله بيعرف
يكتبوا بيطلع الاشكال زي ما هي بالضبط
والتي واللغه العربيه وحب في القراءه كل
الحاجات دي من غيرها اكيد ما كنتش اقدر
اوصل انا وصلت له
ما كان يكون قاعد اقول لكم وكل شويه يعني
احنا هنروح فين
وبعدين بقه ما تقول وخلاص
عموما خلاص خلاص انا
بيتهيالى كده
الهام ايوه عشان حضرتك عارف انا بحب الهرم
ان يفكر اما بالنسبه لي
التوقعات دائما كنت بحب ان خطه وخط
التصورات ثانيه عشان ما بالواقع اول مره
تحركنا بالمكتبه المتنقله وصلنا كانوا
بدانا نشتغل مع الاطفال
انا بشتغل مع الاطفال في السته ابتدائي
وللاسف ما بيعرفوا شيء جمله من ثلاث كلمات
عشان كده انا لازم تغير كل التصور المشتغل
في كلمه المرونه هي اهم حاجه في الشغل
الاطفال ان التاقلم عليهم وتقدر ان تحقق
لهم الحاجه اللي هم عايزينها من غير ما
تفرضها عليها وعرفنا ان احنا نخلي الولاد
هم اللي ساعدوا بعض من غير ما احنا نتدخل
لان المعلومه اللي بتوصل من الولد للولد
او من الطفل للطفل اثر عمليه منها توصل
منها مدى طيب حاضر
وشوف ان اوصل فين
ماشيين لحتى مره واحده وقفوا
تفضل انزل راح نشوف بتاعت ذاكرتين ذاكره
وقال يتفضل عشان تعادي تذكاريه ايه بس مش
حيث تقول لي
التذاكر بالنسبه لي في حياتي هي الشركاء
شركاء النجاح اللي ساعدوني ما فيش حدا
ابدا احنا واحده ناس وساعدت ناس كراسي من
بيوتها عشان تقاعد الاطفال عليها نفتح
بيوتها للاطفال عشان يطلعوا اصابه ويخلوا
كل سبل الراحه اللي يقدروا يقدموها للناس
مش بالقاهره بس بالعكس ده في كل المحافظات
ما فيش ابدا حاجه تنجح من غيرهم
ما كانت ذكرها وعادل ودخل تفضل اول مادخل
بدل ما كان عمال يفرقوا يعني نورت لانهم
واقفين عن ما رسمه راكب
قالها احنا ممكن تعملها لي ما فيش حاجه
احسن من كده وبعدها طبعا
جيدا وثلاثين بيوسع
المنطقه بالنسبه لي او في الحكي لما تحكي
قصتها عامل مشاكل قوه مستشفى الاطفال
وتفاجا ان الام بتضحك هي وابنها وسطهم اخر
البلد اللي تشتغل فيها على ايه على قسم او
ان المكتبه المتنقله المكان اللي يشتغل
فيه وتلاقي الولاده وقفوا طابور من غير ما
تقول لهم لو سمحتوا عشان ندخل لوحدهم
لمجرد ان عارفين انه كل موقف اسرى ان يلعب
اكثر او في الحكي تسمع وتشوف تطلع من
القلب احتاج ما فيش فيها اي حاجه
لما تحكي بس وكتبت تحت او حركه ما هو
بيشكل كل حاجه والعكس بيسمع بيحرك ايده
بيفكروا بيلعب
ما كان يكون كمان كان مبسوط جدا وكذلك ب
المركب وعمليات تمزقت ويتنقل من كل مكان
شويه كانه عايزه كل حتى فيها لكن للاسف
المركبه هي ماشيه في مجموعه من الصخور
واذا اصر عليها وخلي
جزء منها
كل الناس كانت خايفه لكن المراقبه منهم
وقال لهم
الموضوع قبل ان احنا نحل تفضل هاتين وكل
حاجه ها تمشي كويس في المكتبه المتنقله او
في الحكي عموما الفين اماكن كثير اشتغلنا
مع اطفال اكثر وكان هدفنا الاساسي ان احنا
نفك اتهم علنا من اكثر مما كان كان
المشاكل ممكن المكتبه تتعطل عادي جدا اخذ
الخامات على ظهري وسافر واشتغل مع الاطفال
في كل الاماكن وما فيش اي مشكله
بعدما المركبه اللي حصل بدات تلف الثانيه
وللاسف انتخابات من الناحيه الثانيه واخر
عليها وللاسف كثر منها خطتين
بردو المرتبطه منهم واللي ما فيش اي مشكله
كل حاجه تمشي كويس
ممكن تواجهنا مشاكل تصاريح زي ا وراء زي
موافقات عايده جدا خلينا ندور على حلول
بدل ما انخفض الواقفين عندنا مشاكل ان
انتقل في اماكن معينه بدورها على اماكن
عامه مفتوحه وندعوا الاماكن اللي احنا مش
عارفين ندخلها عندنا عقبات في الخامات او
في المديريه
ونشتغل بيهم ونعمل احسن حاجه احنا
عايزينها اهم حاجه هي الاستمراريه والفكره
وانها ما تبقاش مره واحده بس
كميه المركب لكن للاسف المرات اتخذت
والخطه كانت جيده جدا اكثر مع
مسؤولي الكبير ومع كسر المرات وقف المرجو
قال لهم انا اسف جدا الثلاثه انه النقطه
كلنا في الميه والنقطه القريبين مع بعض
عشان يحصل اي مشكله لاي احد وقال لهم على
شويه حكيت
سمعوها معه
في حياتي
الحاجه اللي كسرتني كثير جدا وخليتني انا
منها الحكواتي اللي بيحكي وبيلعب الواحد
ممكن يكون بيشتغل شغله الاداري هي وفاه
زوجتي رحمه الله عليها اللي معاها بطريقتي
انا تماما من اللي بيحكي وانا اسيب
تمنطاشر سنه شغل مع الاطفال
بوتين واضحه عشان اقدر احافظ على اطفالي
وسعادتهم وعاد يهم الحاجه اللي حنا مرينا
فيها
خلينا نرجع ل ما كان يكون في المركز اللي
كلنا
ما حدا شاف فيه حاجه
والسبب
انه كل واحد فيهم كان لابس الله بتاعته
كل واحد كان قوي بتاعته ولما كلهم مع بعض
قويين اكثر واكثر واللافت سعادتهم وانهما
كان مابعد انا كمان لا تاتي اكتشفت انها
كانت في الحكم خليني اقدر اتنفس و ارجع من
تاني ومش الله بس هو الحكي انت جزء من
زوجتي لتوها الله ولادي كل واحد تركوا
يدور على الله بتاعته اللي ها تساعدوا انه
هو يعد كل حاجه وتخيلوا
كتاب صغير جدا
شكرا
[تصفيق]